bonjour anne bouillon merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors un
policier accusé de violences
intrafamiliales qui recueille une
déposition pour des cadres pour un cas
de violence conjugale
c'est en partie ce qui vous choque dans
cette affaire vous allez résoudre c'est
extrêmement choquant c'est même
bouleversant en réalité est ce que ça
dit c'est que l'institution n'est
toujours pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu qui
est une institution a dans ce cas là une
part de responsabilité dans ce drame
absolu de ce féminisme donc sachant que
la no 4 que je suis ça choque la
militant que je suis là parce que je
suis je pense qu on est tous et toutes
pour fonder leur portée par cette mise à
jour de dysfonctionnements néanmoins là
vous pouvez allégations de la cité et
votre sujet rencontre est bien c'est que
maintenant on investigue la chaîne
pénale on réfléchit à la manière dont
les choses se passent à la manière dont
les victimes sont prises en charges ne
sont pas suffisamment prises en charge
et ça c'est un élément nouveau parce que
pendant des décennies evans à elles sont
mortes dans le silence et l'indifférence
la plus totale
aujourd'hui on a une prise de conscience
on a une volonté politique notre société
tout entière
c'est le déteste ces questions là et on
peut espérer que ça impulsa changement
mais le changement est très lent
qu'est ce qui explique aujourd'hui qu'un
policier accusé de violence conjugale
recueille une déposition pour violences
conjugales également est ce que c'est
une défaillance du système de notes de
la police sur ce dysfonctionnement la
soirée fantastique d'une généralité
pendant des années on s'est battu pour
que l'accueil des femmes qui me de
violence conjugale soit amelio moi je me
souviens site façon départ ne pouvait
tout simplement pas avoir associé ont
leur mort est pas déposé plainte
on se contentait simplement pour rendre
si elle n'avait pas sa capitale il
pouvait laver les dents cassées ou les
factures envoyées chez dell ça a été
très compliqué des lieux d'information
les questionnaires nous parler
j'ai eu cette politisation et l'accueil
dans les commissariats des gendarmes à
l'égard de leur rendement mais reste ici
et là des personnes qu'ils ont à la face
la semaine dernière je recevais les
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
jean-marc reconnaissait le fait d avoir
tapé dessus et la policière remettez-le
il ya désormais les autres valorisant le
simple battre explique voyez elle se
laissait aller ce genre de commentaires
à face à ma vie dans absolument
stupéfait et des armées et policières
je pense que ça change je pense que
celle voulue je crois que ça a évolué en
faut mais gare à ce que les notes parce
que vous l'avez dit de ne pas me
continuent de mourir très violent et les
lieux ans à yopal sont à notre quotidien
vous le disiez la situation évolue
lentement en tout cas donc dans le bon
sens
est ce que les policiers les policières
sont aujourd'hui vraiment fort mais
justement à l'accueil des plaignantes
ils ne sont pas toutes et tous il faut
être volontaire pourra très fort mais il
faut qu'une politique pénale du
procureur soit engagée et le programme
ont sauvé c'est que ce magistrat qui va
définir les priorités dans le ressort de
sa compétence en matière de politique et
d'acide procureur on ne met pas dans
lutte contre les violences conjugales
sommet de ses priorités et garçons de
neymar la lutte contre les violences
conjugales n'est pas la priorité
donc c'est toute une chaîne c'est toute
une chaîne pénale qui doit se mettre en
mouvement avec mes premiers rapports
les cigales
alors l information qui sont dispensés
la technique de recueil des plaintes qui
sont améliorées maintenant les policiers
disposent d'un questionnaire ils vont
venir à vesti gay tout les tous les
domaines de la conjugalité une pause ce
fichier peuvent s'initier les des ventes
france et communient je pense aux délits
sexuels transhumance fizi aux violences
morales parce que vous savez les
violences conjugales
ça prend tout un tas de forme différents
et maintenant honda ces questionnaires
la roue avant les politiques pouvaient
se contenter d'investiguer ce que c'est
pourquoi la femme venait déposer une
donc des formations sont au travail
les magistrats de travail mais on a
beaucoup de retard en fait état d'un
nombre vous dire qu'on n'a toujours pas
dire unique sont spécialisés ce qu'il
faut là assurément c'est des policiers
spécialisés sur ces questions n'est
procureur spécialisé se défont des
justes spécialisé sur la question des
violences conjugales pendant le match
les caennais qui a lui la trappe femmes
prennent au sérieux cette classe un
bouillon très rapidement avant de
terminer on a pu beaucoup de temps mais
on l'a vu dans le sujet tout à l'heure
le nombre de féminicide repart à la
hausse là en 2021
pourquoi il n'y a pas ce que nos
politiques pénales ne sont pas la leur
la célébration sera franchement argent
pour nos bonnes âmes en parler eh bien
on attend encore un pic soit effectif
s'offrir un en espagne on dit en avance
sur nous son bras sans retour à
franchement aucune part dotée de ceux de
ce mécanisme de protection n'a été tué
voilà il faut protéger les femmes elles
sont passibles d'amendés merci beaucoup
anne bouillon d'avoir été
avec nous sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes avocate en droit des femmes
merci beaucoup